is getting that getting a good strong
no you getting a good strong position
okay and you're going to try and stop
him pushing you here
right right go on
that's it
all right good is he pushing enough
okay come come
come now you're going to hold him with
this hand
and
and you know we
you know we just had
this this feeling but really it was that
see this is the feeling but my mind
knows it's that direction
but if i do that and that he'll know
that it's that direction so when you
hold him when you hold him
you're going to actually be pushing the
end to
george
hold it more lightly
no but is it easier than when you was on
the front
okay okay so let let me have your hand
now
okay right now push
let me have your hand
okay
but that's what we're aiming for
you're aiming for
the direction he doesn't know
because this is the direction again
because i actually fight with myself
so
i'm changing his direction
mentally
okay
you can
on a good night i could put it on there
where it can slip off and still get it
because that's again
because that's the
i can't do it but again that's the
direction
over there
so i'm defying angles and this is what
you're doing he wasn't really pushing so
that's okay
all right so you're defining so you're
going to get a ken now and you're going
to try and do do that
on each other